hey there wordsmiths this video is about
the word align a line this word has two
definitions the first is to support Ally
or associate with someone and the second
definition is to put things in a
straight line that's its literal
definition it comes from the Latin Lin
which means line it's a very useful
little word and it is a verb now I'm
gonna throw y'all a 10 second music
break and in that time see how many
words you can come up with that use Lin
Please Mr music won't you play
[Music]
foreign here are some words I came up
with earlier cooking show style linear
which means in a straight line to
delineate which means to describe in
detail or Draw out borders and perhaps
obviously the word line itself but let's
dive into a lie because if you're
anything like me you're wondering about
that g why isn't it a ligand
I will spare you the lecture and say
simply that it came from French don't
worry about it we just don't say it in
the same way we don't say the G in sign
or at least we don't say it as a g sound
I I find this stuff fascinating I could
basically keep talking about this
forever but I'm trying to keep these
videos short and snackable so let's use
a line in some sentences you can use it
literally right like all lined up when
the planet's aligned our powers were at
their greatest right you can draw a
straight line from Neptune straight
through to the sun straight enough uh
the planets
aligned
but you can also use it figuratively
non-literally to say that people agree
Jamel and I aligned on the fact that the
cereal milk is the best part of
breakfast
here we are in fact
in agreement in alignment in fact I'll
write that down so it's just that this
is the noun form we've added m-e-n-t to
turn it into a noun in alignment
and one last sentence Supriya had to
align with the other Rebels she had to
get in line they had to link up so I
hope you and I are all aligned on the
meaning of this word because I'm out of
time until the next one you can learn
anything David out